みなさん、こんにちは。このビデオでは
、ドーゲンによる日本語音声学の第2話へようこそ。
このシリーズの構成と内容の背景を提供するトピックを使用して、日本語の学歴
について話し、日本語の学習経験について話します。
いくつかの日本語について説明し
ます。 プログラム
これらのリソースをチェックするために出発する前に、このビデオ全体をご覧になることを
お勧めします。
ビデオが続くにつれて、私が
中学2年生のときに自分で日本語を勉強し始めた理由を理解でき
ます。
地元の中古書店のカセットテープと教科書1冊で
、プログラム
を終えるまでプログラムを終えるまで
、毎晩就寝直前に1回レッスンを行い
、内容に
自信がないときは日本語で何度もレッスンを繰り返しました。 良い
プログラムです。日本語を
始めたいと思って
いる人には、デュアルマジラトを使用することを強くお勧めします。
ひらがなカタカナや漢字よりも
悪いのですが、これは特に悪い
ことではないと思います。
オックスフォードシリーズを終えた後、ピムスルールの日本のロゼッタストーン
など、他のいくつかのプログラムを試した理由を説明
します。 非常にゆっくり
とまとまりがなく、何よりもむなしい私
は、
武道をトリッキーに始めたとき、そして
高校1年生のときに積極的に日本語を勉強するのをやめましたが、毎日
日本の音楽を聴き続け、
毎週5〜10時間
日本語のインターネット
テレビを見ました 私が初めて日本語の授業を受けたとき、日本の主要なレコードレーベルの1つであるAvoxは、
私が長い間積極的に日本語を勉強していなかったため、ワシントン大学の大学2年生のときに日本語を勉強していたことを示しています。
日本語の頼りになるリソースは、ドール
マジベースのプログラムでした。配置テストでうまくいきませんでした。
結局
、日本語101に配置されたので
、日本語の紹介をしました。
このクラスに参加して、
言語学101にも申し込みました。この
コースで、私の日本の学習習慣を根本的に変える2つのことを学びました。1
つのライティングシステム世界の約半数の
言語には、
これらの
言語が考慮されているにもかかわらず、ライティングシステムがありません。
生きている言語は話せるが書けない生きている言語は
書けないが話せないということを
簡単に言えば、この知識から
、口頭言語の場合の口頭言語における言語の光の本質は、
中国語の文字で表される
日本語の文字ローマ字の
アルファベット国際的な音声のアルファベットなどです
が、どの
ように単語を書いても書かなくても、話し言葉
自体は変わらず、話し言葉
を正確に模倣する脳の能力
は時間の経過とともに大幅に低下します。
ほとんどの人がそうであるように、このコースを受講する前にこれを行いますが
、この現象について学びます 明確な
数字と学術研究
を前述の点と組み合わせることで、
日本語の
ネイティブのようなアクセントを開発することが私の目標の1つであったため、実際に勉強
の
習慣を変えることになりました。
たくさんの漢字を覚えたり
、日本語で高学年になろうとするのではなく、その特定の時間に私の日本語の発音と高低アクセントが私のレキシコンや語彙の範囲内でネイティブに近いと感じるまで、音声学への努力と基本的に他のすべてを延期します 101私は午後を借りました
鈴木さんの大学図書館での日本語の音声学は
、勉強時間の大部分を
一人で発音に集中して過ごしまし
た。情報を適切に処理し
たかったので、また私の主
なものである他のクラスのトリックで非常に忙しかったので、意図的にゆっくりとこれを行いまし
た。 当時の情熱と時が
経つにつれて私のパートタイムの仕事
はますます
日本の音声学に興味を持つようになり、最終的に
は私の専攻を
国際ビジネスから日本の
言語学に変更することにし
ました。 音韻論や音声
学よりも形態構文と社会言語学の方が多い
ので、私の進行中の
音声学の研究はほとんどの場合
、授業の外で行わ
れました。
下位レベルのクラスに配置した言語能力の観点からです
が、
アクセント
は中級クラスや上級クラスのほとんどの生徒と同等でしたが、
それでも話す能力に満足できず
、一年中
海外で話すことに集中し
て漢字を使うべきだと強く信じていました。 または高度な文法なので
、日本語
を学ぼうとする外国人ではなく、日本人のネイティブに囲まれるように、できるだけ少ないクラスでいくつかのことをしました。
日本語の
先生に、最初の高低アクセントを開くまで高低アクセントを教えてもらい
ました。 親切な高低
アクセントクラスと3人私は
カオス国際寮を出て
、東京での1年間に日本人家族とホームステイを始めました。一生懸命勉強
し、シアトルへの帰りの飛行機に乗るまでに、
会話が流暢であるように感じました。 日本語、つまり
、ほとんどの日常会話を
自然な速さで理解し、参加することができ、さらに、日本語の高低アクセントを感じました。
entは
、n1テストに合格し、
日本語の
クラスではなく、日本語の経済学などの通常のクラスを
受講している学生
を含め、その年に留学した学生の中で最高の学生の1人でした。 アメリカに戻り
、日本の言語学の学位を取得した後
、ジェットプログラムで日本に戻りまし
た。この頃に
は、音声学の研究でリターンが減少しているように感じ、
最終的に読書に焦点を移すことに決めました。
筆記私は
3年間のほとんどすべての時間を
ジェットプログラムに費やし、短編小説
と日本語を書き
、以前のドーゲンで話し言葉と書き言葉の両方を勉強していた言語8などのウェブサイトを通じてネイティブスピーカーに修正してもらいました。
そして、
私
が約4、5年前からやって
いる日本語でのsoleyクリエイティブライティングに焦点を合わせ始めました。
私は現在、
日本語
と英語の
両方を家で話せる
ので
、日本語の教育の歴史を要約すると、日本人の女性と結婚しています。
10代前半は自分で約1年半
日本語を勉強し
ました。高校中は音楽のテレビ番組や映画を通してネイティブ日本語に触れてい
ました。大学全体で集中
的に日本語を勉強
しました。 大学で
書かれた日本語に追いつき
、それ以来ずっと
日本語で短い物語やエッセイを書き
、ほとんど日本語の環境で働き、生活している
ので、最初の日本語の勉強を意図的に日本語に限定すること
が、 日本語の話し言葉
は現在のレベルです私は
多くの悪い話し方を避けることができました 言語を包括
的に勉強するとすぐに発達
します。いつでも
漢字や古風な文法を学ぶことができます
が、年をとるにつれて
外国語の音を模倣するのは比較的
難しくなり
、悪い習慣が確立されるとそれを修正するのはさらに難しくなります。
良い習慣を確立するよりも悪い習慣を忘れるのはこのため
、日本語で離陸を使用することは
、弓の絵文字ベースの日本のリソース
が特に悪いことであり、私
がすべての注意を何であるかに集中させることができたとは思わない理由です
聞くことと
読むこと、話すことと書くことの間で私の注意を分割させるのではなく、ここ
で物事が半ば物議を醸す
ところです。 あなたの最終的な目標は
、ネイティブのようなアクセントを開発することです。特に話すことと書くことの間で
勉強時間を均等に分割することは非生産的です。
y初級および
中級レベルでは
、高低アクセントのパターンを覚えずに新しいことを学ぶたびに
、悪い音声習慣が発達する可能性
があると思います。したがって、あなたが言語シバンで
はなく、生活の贅沢がなかったと仮定します。 子供の頃の
日本の環境では、
ネイティブまたはネイティブに近い
発音をするためには、できるだけ早く音声学を勉強
する必要があり、現在日本語を勉強していて、最終的にはほとんど話さないことを望んでいる場合は、これらの勉強を真剣に受け止めなければならないと思います
-to-外国語のアクセントなし私の
個人的なアドバイスは
、日本語と語彙の
勉強を減らし、この時間を
高低アクセントと
発音パターンの記憶に割り当てること
です。インスピレーションの
練習は完璧な練習にはなりません。
知識と
意図的にずらした学習計画で
、ガイジンのアクセントをお尻に
挟みます私のシリーズの日本語のふりがなを願っています ics
は、これを達成するために使用する多くのリソースの1つになります。
これで、レッスン3のこのレッスンで
は、日本語の音声学に関する一般的な誤解について説明します。レッスン
4では、音声
認識と有用な音声学の実践について説明
します。レッスン5では、
日本語のアクセントの
用語の紹介を開始し
ます。音声学の研究を補足するために使用できるさまざまな無料のサードパーティリソース
がすぐに提供さ
れます。今後ともよろしくお願いいたします。また
お会いしましょう
[音楽]